hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2014 it's day
three the dream is almost over for
another 12 months but don't worry we've
got a bunch of amazing games on the game
spot stage today NHL 15 EA Sports UFC we
got FIFA not a hero battle cry loads of
great stuff and we're starting off with
a bang or arena of fate I'm very happy
to be joined with David Bowman from
Crytek hey do and sir
doing very well thank you you didn't
have to walk very far your booth is
right there very convenient
yeah absolutely great to have you here
so AB you guys have been working with
the Black Sea Studios and which is now
Black Sea Crytek or husband for quite a
while I guess in stage and this is the
first game that's being released solely
out of that studio entirely developed
from that studio yes and so for folks
who don't know about it because in
fairness you only bonanzas at the end of
May what this was and it's playable here
actually immediately only a month and a
half later so the folks at home might
not know what arena fate is just give
the sort of brief description what I'm
sure it's a it's a 5 vs. 5 team arena
battle game it's 20 minute limited so we
know right from the beginning that
you'll be playing for 20 minutes and
it's intense combat during that time and
the goal is to have the most points at
the end of 20 minutes or to score the
first team to score 10 points wins cool
so you're staying away from the the idea
of being sort of corralled with the word
MOBA because it's becoming quite a
reductive phrase as it worth it is yeah
a MOBA is a great term for those people
who have a very narrow need this gave a
little bit broader than that
we're hoping a lot more accessible than
some of the traditional MOBAs yes
awesome all right so let's have a look
at the moment-to-moment gameplay because
I feel that with any multiplayer a
tactical game it's that's what sort of
differentiates one for the others so
we're looking at some b-roll now you
just explain what's happening sure right
now I'm actually at this point I was
actually playing Jack the Ripper okay
and Jack the Ripper's following king
Lionheart we're flowing across sort of
the middle lane right now this is a
three lane game but the middle names
little lane is a very different
experience in there you're what you're
trying to do in the middle lane is you
try to knock down that first tower to
get to the crystal beyond it if you
knocked that crystal down it'll lower
the shields on the other towers and the
other lanes okay and so it's less
rewarding in some ways but the reward if
you do make it all the way through
allows you to make a big difference in
the game and so the different characters
you have in this you guys have gone have
gone
human mythos exactly all basically all
treat all humans throughout throughout
history whether they're historically
real characters or whether they're from
fiction lore and from around the world
so we're mixing together a lot of very
interesting characters who have not been
seen in games before so you've got skies
light you've got Tesla Tesla's fantast
that's a real person yes Red Riding Hood
fictional lesson I don't think so yes
and who has he got Robin Hood Robin
Hood's there right now in the scene I
think so I see
Baron von Munchausen is in there
Blackbeard was running around earlier
Tesla's on this green is that some sort
of sparking that is what we're gonna do
is we have 30 heroes already that'll be
released in our closed beta and we'll be
talking about them as we go along and
we're gonna let people actually sort of
discover who some of these characters
are between now and then rather than
reveal everybody right now and say who
they are I think it's kind of fun to go
okay who would you possibly have in this
game yeah but we have all 30 of them set
up right now and we've developed others
that were actually polishing and working
on at the same time and we'll be adding
those in the future cool so 30 seems
like a kind of a healthy number one of
the most intimidating things about other
games that might be you could say would
be similar today's is that there is
quite a lot of people to choose from and
perhaps sometimes a devil's advocate
sometimes that thought a man of choice
can be overwhelming to be overwhelming
for many people but I think one of the
reasons we decided actually what the
core premises of the game was can we
make this more accessible to people and
less about oh I have to go research to
believe in play the game yeah and what
we've done is we try to simplify the
gameplay down to its core elements and
so we don't have hundreds of thousands
of or even thousands of items that you
have to go research on the internet nor
didn't lay the game we have the the
tactical decisions happening within the
game so you're actually the only
decisions you make after you started
playing is- level 2 i get to pick a new
ability out of a small list of abilities
right there in the interface so you
don't have to leave the battle to do it
and then as you level up basically till
level 8 and your ranking decisions along
the way of oh i wanna be a little faster
a little stronger which are very easy
decisions for people to make based on
how the games going for them cool so
yeah we're trying to make it
one of those games that you can teach
your friends to play so you have other
people to play with so it doesn't have
that sort of 25 hour learning curve yeah
I think we thought that was quite
overwhelming quite intimidating for most
people and the name of the game is arena
fade
how many arenas are in it right now
we're concentrating in the first one and
we believe that once that is as polished
and as fun as a composite we feel we
might look at others we've obviously
iterated made lots of different maps of
the process so we learned some lessons
there but we think this one being
perfectly symmetrical left to the right
is a very fair map and it's got the
right distances that we like as far as
making sure you can stay in the action
you can get from lane to Lane if you
decide there's a an advantage to being
somewhere else without having to travel
too far what's traditionally called the
jungle the center part of the map is
fairly tight and so you're not spending
a long time sort of wandering through it
trying to get to the action because this
is a 20-minute game yes we want to keep
things constantly in motion so you start
right away or in battle you're hunting
one of the most popular things where
people is hunting the other heroes and
so we wanted to be able to make sure
that you got into that right away and
felt sort of successful at doing that
now because it is the big part of the
game you get you basically have to do
seven kills to get your first point so
seven kills will get you a point okay or
knocking it down a tower gives you a
point or hunting a Titan a Titan is one
of the creatures that spawns a little
bit later in the game in that jungle
area it's an NPC it's an NPC very tough
very hard to kill but work an entire
point and in this game frequently the
battles are decided by one or two points
because there's a 20 minute time limit
we didn't have to create that mechanic
of snowballing yeah you know because if
you have an open-ended game that you
don't know when it's gonna end you know
why your players playing for days
you want to have a chance for them to
win so you put a snowballing effect in
and one team gets better and better and
better the other team sets buying goes a
lot less is useless we wanted a loss
this is a 20 minute match and make a
sport right it has a timer and the team
stay competitive the whole time and
there's very rarely a blowout and in the
matchmaking system we can very easily
account for because you pick your hero
first rather than entering into the game
and then choosing your hero there's no
competition over who you're playing our
matchmaking system can easily go and
look at
here's this hero here's this hero this
account has played Rider a lot he's
probably pretty good at that we can look
at the value okay yeah he's good let's
look at let's bring these guys together
so we had a good competition so do you
pick the heroes as you're entering
matchmaking rather than being much much
and then they're being picked in front
of everyone's acting all right so our
matchmaking system was in an effort
we've done everything we can to
eliminate the conflict within the party
right my team okay be all about teamwork
it shouldn't be about one person's glory
or arguments about who gets to play whom
we think that's kind of limiting is
there player leveling within the game or
we track the account leveling so we know
how many times you played Little Red
Riding Hood okay so your account will be
leveling up Little Red Riding Hood and
that's part of the meta game and we're
not yet ready to talk about entirely
about the meta game because we're still
learning from our audience we started a
friends-and-family beta and we're
learning from them really yeah and we
were taking right now if we go to arena
of fate calm yeah you can sign up for
our beta for our closed beta and we've
announced a time frame of summer for
that to start okay but testings going
very very well it's also early summer
because today it's going really well you
guys are ready to open up the doors and
we're gonna be cautious about that we
want to make sure that we get a good
strong core audience and listen to them
really really well but once we get that
feedback going we'll be iterating quite
quickly on the game so you guys seem to
be trimming at some of what people would
now say the established rule sets or
mechanics of a game of this ilk so for
instance the farming stuff that happens
at the start of games like dota 4 it's
like if you have an if you have an
open-ended game you want phases to it
you want people to be able to develop a
long strategic play and then the
exciting part sort of happens near the
end in a 20-minute time to match your
goals are very different your goal is to
keep people very very entertained and
active and and it should have that sort
of that pace of a 20 minute sports event
but you know that being said those games
that are very very successful right now
people love those games and we don't
necessarily want to go make a cloneable
game because
they're already playing those games
they'll be silly to go after and say oh
I wouldn't make another one of those
exact games so we said what can we do
that would be entertaining for people
who aren't being satisfied by the game
so is that is there another way - can
you finish the game before 20 minutes is
there yes absolutely the first team to
ten points wins okay or if you can get
all the way to the tower at the base
tower at the end and destroy that base
tower it doesn't matter what the score
is you can have also win that being said
our towers are a lot more challenging
than some of the other towers like
you'll see in some of this footage that
as a minion Dominion comes up that tower
can kill a minion in one hit okay right
and so their minions are kind of popcorn
the heroes are really the core of the
game but the towers will only aim at
those minions as long as there's minions
there so you use the minions as shields
for your for your heroes so you're
really kind of coordinated be a good
team to be able taking down towers it's
not this game isn't focused on
territorial expansion yeah and that's
sort of a core of traditional MOBAs is
that in order to win this game we want
to sweep this Lane and we want to be
able take all those towers down as
territorial expansion yeah but that is a
viable strategy but it's not the only
strategy seems more about accruing
points and I wholly it's a it's a
support and kind of game yeah like how
could I score the most baskets how can
it kick the most goals yeah perfect I
want to go to the chopper we got a bunch
of crises coming in sir Lord - 1014 hind
asks will the game feature online
microtransactions
and that will make it pay to win oh well
are you free to play first of all we are
free to play we're a game as the service
does we wanted we want to grow this
overtime we want to listen to the
audience and keep feeding back to them
so there has to be some form of
economics involved so yes there are
micro transactions involved but we don't
believe in pay to win at all we use the
phrase play to win we think that you
know your skill as a players what should
count so we're gonna be selling unlocks
of new heroes because we've got thirty
heroes you won't be able to have all 30
em right at the beginning well one thing
I will say we don't take heroes away
like if you have Robin Hood you can play
Robin Hood every single day for the rest
of your life if you want to that's
that's fine with us but you're gonna be
unlocking heroes that'll be a cost
you'll be able to choose cosmetics for
you know we've got skins and we've got
customizations for each of the arrows
but it's actually pretty cool because we
sell still has to be it still has to
feel like Tesla
yeah yeah but Tesla with a mohawk what
you look like so you know there's
opportunity to Center for
microtransactions and as we go into
closed beta we're not gonna start closed
beta with our monetization system in
place yeah we actually want to listen to
our audience and say hey do we have a
fun game first and if Excel shorts
church-turing their base though who
Messalina hajiyev who is the creative
lead in the sophia black studio black
flexi studio he is insistent this game
has to be fun first monetization is the
second issue if you have a fun game with
a growing growing audience there's you
know you'll be able to make enough money
off of that to keep growing that game
but if you don't have that core fun then
people aren't excited about your game
that no monetization scheme gonna change
that it's crazy you guys are Crytek I've
got fingers in so many pies at this
stage and it's it's interesting to see
you spread out of I guess what people
would associate most of Crytek which is
blockbuster massive first-person
experience right and what is that it's
not a sort of within the culture of
krycek-- cuz you're in the frankfurt
office
yeah is that a notable thing where
they're trying to sort of go into
different areas and see what sticks so
we've become really really good at the
first-person shooter we have we have a
beautiful wonderful engine right
CryEngine is fantastic
this is the CryEngine as well we wanted
to know can we take studios who are
really skilled at other genres grow them
into the Crytek methodologies and
deliver high-quality first-class
experiences for customers in different
genres we're you know we're becoming
more than simply a developer of a single
type of game and it's really exciting I
mean it's it it's a wonderful place to
work and having that atmosphere of okay
what do we want to tackle next what are
we gonna do really really well and so we
believe we've got a very good entry into
this admittedly competitive field yeah
but it's also the fastest growing
consumer base in the world right this
people love this experience and we're
all players as well we're all fans so
it's nothing we're checking out David
Bowman Crytek thank you so much for
coming new game spot stage and showing
us arena fades
one last time for the folks who are
interested in getting to internet bata
whenever it's on www
of fate comm perfect simple as yes you
can see it it's written on the wall
right there's a big television wasn't in
the way
Oh III advertise
I'd be fantastic